circus circus officially released its
full schedule of circus shows for the
first time since the pandemic and rocky
theis
is their newest act for the day so grab
some popcorn
enjoy the show welcome
to the world's famous midway of circus
circus
today starring rocco
[Music]
and rocky
back on rocky rocco and rocky we're the
new axe here
at circus circus yay the full schedule
of free circus acts here at the world
famous midway this is a little different
now because during the pandemic
obviously they had
limited shows
oh yeah i'm excited about it everybody's
excited about it
we're in vegas it's going to open up
again baby oh my god
absolutely we are excited we've got
people already sitting down waiting for
the next show to start so rocco
what kind of shows can people catch here
daily oh well you can see the trapeze
hacks you can see the jugglers you can
see contortion you can see
everything you want to see when you come
here what kind of stuff do you do you
told me you're a physical comedian
comedian what do you say i mean that
means i do things physically
i'm not a joke funny thing like this hi
oh my god see that's physical comedy it
is
you're hilarious right now you're
hilarious so naturally i think since i'm
on stage i should learn a thing or two
oh yes you should i should
chuck the juggler there we are hey guys
okay
you're going to teach me how to juggle
yes okay
you guys are doing the cool stuff but i
don't think i can handle that
okay rocco yes you gotta talk
again you wanna catch me through this
you wanna coach me yeah
one two three oh oh oh you're so close
so close so close oh shoot okay try one
more time one more time
one two three oh look at that oh
oh how about that did i get a round of
applause
my fish can't even do that all right
i'm just letting you guys know that the
free circus shows are back memorial day
weekend they start
the full schedule is here so on the hour
every half hour
now rocky it's every hour on the half
hour oh
you're good for something rocco come on
down bring your family
oh my gosh excuse us excuse us